bonjour à tous
il est 18h45
on est en direct merci d'être avec nous
que ça va le public très en forme
aujourd'hui de ouf il est avec nous je
suis très heureux de recevoir un ami
franck dubosc est avec lui
[Applaudissements]
ils ont été remis au talent tout faire
en ce moment je sais qu'ici tous les
chroniqueurs se faisait une joie de
recevoir
franck dubosc parce que vous trouvez
qu'il a un immense talent comme en plus
c'était vraiment un ami quand j'ai un
ami si vraiment on aime ou pas rien à
part jusqu'à cet après midi mais voilà
rien cet après midi franck ah ouais
quand même
et je le dis devant la france entière tu
vas bien un coup de couteau dans le dos
dans le savoir h 30
je sais que tu prépares ton prochain
long métrage rumba la vie
malheureusement franck je suis tombé
sur cette petite annonce aujourd'hui un
homme 35 50 ans sachant bien jouer au
ping pong pour film prendre du boss
réalisé par et avec franck dubosc et là
ils cherchent quelqu'un sachant très
bien joué au ping pong pour ton film et
tu vas vous dire qu à aucun instant tu
n'as pas pensé à moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu sais que tu fais pas tu fais là de
chiffres là tout à coup en quoi c'est
une bonne idée nantes où alonzo tall
audi enfin on peut dire et tout de suite
je suis très content et travailler parce
que il est vraiment d'avoir ça parce que
c'est un hommage aux mamans c'est ça aux
femmes se seraient donnés dès qu'on soit
cod ça donne pas de leçons mais un
hommage aux mamans et avant tout à la
maman de mes enfants et voilà on
embrasse talent égal adore en plus c'est
un amour et c'est un petit peu grâce à
moi site avec elle aujourd'hui je vous
le dis on était ensemble à monaco on
était une soirée et c'est vrai que
franck est venu me voir mais il m'a dit
j'ai craqué pour la jeune fille là bas
on était allé à une soirée tous les deux
et moi je me suis retrouvé comme un
conte toute la soirée en parler avec 7
et parler avec sa future femme et moi je
me suis retrouvé tout seul a batu sa
tête à côté de nous oui mais bon j'étais
en back up j'étais en back up
à côté d'eux mêmes à joueur marat nu
dans un instant mal à nu est ce qu'il y
aura d'autres matches c'est bon ce matin
tony pour la bonne cause vous verrez ça
dans un instant puisque lui il s'est mis
tout nu pour la bonne cause on stars à
nu c'est philippe candeloro marché
[Applaudissements]
merci m la motion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la démence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
idriss nous a rejoint informaticien
spécialisé dans le piratage
il risque il va vous faire flipper votre
tête paraît que tu peux faire des trucs
de fou pas que tu peux mettre ses huit
sur tf1 c'est possible voire impossible
non mais c'est pas une blague
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
venez ils sont tous dehors ils doivent
faire un toc toc toc
venez on fait une barca on n'est jamais
rentré qui veut faire l'émission avec
moi aujourd'hui
la chérie mais toi là allez vas-y mes
toiles à mes toiles à mettons-la vas-y
mes toiles mes toiles à ahvaz et mes
toiles à mes toiles
gérer toi bien la régie riaa qui est
super dans l'avenir antoni je suis
étudiant infirmier troisième année tu es
content d'être avec nous alors je suis
heureux c'est la deuxième fois que je
suis autour de cette table quoi j'avais
participé à la télé même l'été non en
jeu oui c'est pas très bien marché on
est inquiète pas là aujourd'hui tu vois
le gars me donne les autres d'un truc il
ya cinq ans on avait fait 280 unités des
spectateurs s'étaient pas c'était pas
fou beau merci mon chéri tu me regardes
top chef dit la vérité
c'est pourquoi pour garder top chef
damien j'aime beaucoup parce que déjà ma
copine adore ça donc je regardais japon
elle adore les toits pour les chefs et
on a essayé d'ailleurs pas de participer
à cette émission
on a candidaté tous ah bon on n'a pas
été retenu c'est quoi ta de présenter ma
spécialité je ne sais pas voilà à quoi
je et endurant trois stars de pékin
express
[Applaudissements]
le rappeur et acteur français stomy
bugzy mon frère et là j'ai vu des
critiques sur la pièce sont
exceptionnelles la bonne critique est de
stomie il a travaillé comme un fou on se
trouve ça fait des semaines et des
semaines et que je le vois et qui me dit
je le travaille je travaille je
travaille il veut même plus aller boire
un café ou prendre un petit pain au
chocolat avec moi ou rien il veut
travailler vous travaillez votre avis
rigide travail qu'est ce que je te dis
[Applaudissements]
l'heure est venu dans ma loge me raconte
tout et n des bons jours il fait que ça
après elle parfait mais c'est clara
mortels mais j'adore c'est vrai j'ai
tout son album chez ses albums alors
avant nous faire une blague
elles sont là on peut pas faire pour
faire un kiff une petite danse carabins
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas d'accord
[Applaudissements]
c'est un mec il dit à sa femme et que
c'était 50 ans je t'offre un voyage au
kenya
sa femme elle est contente je tnt
l'amour de ma vie je veux titi tout pour
moi à lui dit mais si assez content tu
m'envoies au kenya quel match quel
cadeau de choix me faire pour mes 60 ans
a dit porter 60 ans je veux dire que
chercher à tort car les accéderont